you can watch this and other programs
online at booktv.org
instinct take instinct exactly
you must start
you all ready
okay
so thank you so much for coming tonight
this is the hoover series security by
the book
and i'm very pleased to have my friend
and former colleague at the university
of chicago john mearsheimer to talk
about his great new book the great
delusion
liberal dreams and international
realities it's a
pretty scathing and to my mind
convincing critique of american foreign
policy for at least the last few decades
uh so john thanks for coming i'm just
going to start off by asking you to tell
us what the book's about
basically this is a book about american
foreign policy in the post-cold war
period
and my principal goal was to try to
explain why our foreign policy has been
largely a failure especially since 2001
and my basic argument is that we've
pursued this foreign policy which i call
liberal hegemony and to understand
liberal hegemony you have to understand
the relationship between liberalism
nationalism and realism so in a very
important way it's a book about the
relationship between those three isms
and the core argument is that
nationalism and realism beat liberalism
i.e liberal hegemony at every turn and
that explains why we're in so much
trouble today so you need to explain for
the audience what you mean by liberal
hegemony you're not talking about
republicans versus democrats yeah let me
just be very clear in
what i mean when i use the term liberal
i'm not talking about democrats as
liberals and republicans as
conservatives i'm using the word
liberalism in the lockheed sense of the
term
and in my story both
republicans and democrats are liberals
this is not to say there aren't
differences between the two but they're
both liberals we live in a liberal
democracy
and in that sense uh
well people from both parties are
thoroughly liberal now what exactly is
liberal hegemony my argument is that
liberal hegemony is a policy it's a
foreign policy that's designed to remake
the world in america's image
and there are three elements involved
the first and the most important is to
spread democracy all over the planet and
this of course leads us to go around the
world knocking off regimes toppling
authoritarian leaders and trying to
promote democracy that's number one
number two is to promote an open
international economy and do everything
we can to get countries all around the
world
deeply enmeshed in that open
international economy
and then the third goal is to
also get countries all around the world
deeply enmeshed in the international
institutions that we the united states
largely created after world war ii so
those are the basic goals and the belief
is that if you can make the world
look like america right
the end result will be number one you
will eliminate human rights violations
all around the world because as you all
know liberal democracies don't violate
human rights or individual rights on a
massive scale and if the world is
comprised of only liberal democracies
the problem is taken off the table
second if the world is comprised of
nothing but liberal democracies you will
get peace because liberal democracies
don't fight each other according to the
liberal story and once you get peace the
terrorism problem is taken off the table
and the proliferation problem is taken
off the table and then the third great
benefit is you make the world safe for
democracy as you know inside any liberal
state you're going to have elements that
are unhappy with liberalism they may be
communists during the cold war or what
have you and those people who don't like
liberalism
seek allies in other countries i.e
communists looking to the soviet union
to help them but if the world is
comprised of only liberal democracies
those disenchanted people inside your
liberal democracy have no foreign allies
again woodrow wilson referred to this as
making the world safe for democracy so
this is really what liberal demo liberal
uh hegemony is all about so can you walk
us through the catalog of failures that
are attributable to this commitment
just the highlights yeah i i i think
there are three big highlights uh the
first is the bush doctrine and the bush
doctrine of course was all about
spreading democracy in the middle east
uh
iraq was just the first stop on the
railroad line we were going to promote
democracy in syria in iran and so forth
and so on uh and of course that was a
catastrophic failure the amount of blood
that we have on our hands given what's
happened in the middle east
is just hard to describe
second great failure is uh nato
expansion
uh and eu expansion and our efforts uh
to
take those two institutions nato and eu
and march them up to russia's doorstep
and create a giant zone of peace in
western and eastern europe this of
course led to the crisis over ukraine
most americans believe that russia is
responsible for the ukraine crisis i
don't believe that for one second the
united states and his west european
allies are responsible for the crisis
over ukraine because we thought
foolishly because we were thinking like
liberals not like realists that we could
actually march an alliance that was a
mortal enemy of the soviet union right
up to russia's doorsteps and of course
it all blew up in our face and then the
third great policy failure is engagement
with china most of the proponents of
that view who thought that engaging
china would turn it into democracy and
then we would have love peace and dope
from there on out have now admitted that
it was a failure and instead what we did
was help create a behemoth
okay so before i get to questioning some
elements of that thesis
one reason i think why america one
reason it's often given for why this
liberal hegemony strategy might work is
that it worked after world war ii and
it's every element i think that you
described remaking the world in the
american image
an open economy commitment to
international institutions
was
now maybe you want to say that wasn't an
era of international hegemony because
there was a bipolar situation with the
soviet union i'm just wondering how do
you distinguish what the united states
did just after world war ii which seemed
relatively successful maybe you want to
contest that to what happened after 89
or 2001 well let me just say generally
what we did after world war ii
uh up till the end of the cold war was
extremely successful there's no question
about it but it seems to have the patina
of of liberalism as an element of
foreign policy
so why am i wrong about that the key
word is patina okay all right
yeah
look
in the book i argue that the only world
in which you can have the united states
pursuing liberal hegemony is a unipolar
world it's very important to emphasize
this because in a unipolar world where
the united states by definition is the
only great power is the soul pole it is
free to pursue liberal hegemony
otherwise it has to behave in a realist
fashion so if you're in a bipolar war
you're in a bipolar world like we were
during the cold war you have to act
largely according to the dictates of
realism
now with regard to those three elements
spreading democracy and open
international economy and international
institutions first of all
there's no question that if we could
turn a state like germany or japan into
a democracy we would do it seder is
parabush you'll take a democracy over an
autocracy every time but we spent we
spent resources trying to make that
happen not great resources and we were
willing to live with some real thugs uh
during the cold war and we were often
times willing to behave in very
heavy-handed manners uh a very
heavy-handed manner right right
so uh so spreading democracy was not a
high priority
right what was of the highest priority
was balancing against the soviet union
now with regard to international
institutions there's no way in a highly
interdependent modern world you can get
away without having institutions so we
created nato nato was not a liberal
institution nato was created to fight
the cold war and in fact lots of the
institutions that we created including
the eu were largely created for security
reasons this is not to say that they are
not also
liberal in a certain sense
and in fact institutions can be both
realist and liberal at the time but the
fact is that during the cold war
virtually everything we did was designed
to deal with the soviet union right
and so
those seemed like cases where it's hard
to tell how much of the strategy is
being driven by realism and with with a
patina of liberal hegemony and one might
say i assume you'll disagree with this
but just
for purposes of argument
that a lot of the 911 post 911
strategies that you talked about say the
response in afghanistan
and the response in iraq however
misplaced it was uh was driven not by
that the desire for democracy was kind
of
the the trailing
reason and that really we went to
afghanistan because that was the source
and the location of this massive attack
on the homeland and we thought we had to
go in and clean it up so i'm just
wondering if i mean how do you know how
can you tell when when these when these
policies are driven by this liberalism
impulse as opposed to some realist
impulse yeah and there's often mixed
motives i assume and making different
people have different motives let's just
talk about afghanistan and iraq and the
bush doctrine more generally
there's no question just to take a rack
that we went into iraq
in large part because we wanted to deal
with the terrorism problem and the
proliferation problem as you remember
the bush administration thought that
saddam was joined at the hip with
terrorists and might give weapons of
mass destruction to terrorists so i
agree completely
with you when you say that that was the
reason we went into iraq
but we went into iraq with the thought
in mind that we could solve that problem
by turning iraq and its neighbors into
liberal democracies that would create a
giant zone of peace in the middle east
it would take the terrorism problem
and
the proliferation problem off the table
so it's a liberal solution to some very
nasty problems right a good realist like
me is mainly concerned about the balance
of power and when you start talking
about invading countries like iraq right
i say to myself you're really asking for
big trouble this is like going into
vietnam with the soviets going into
afghanistan i used to argue during the
cold war but the soviets went into
afghanistan in 1979. virtually everybody
in the national security establishment
was aghast they thought this was the end
of the world the soviets were on the
march i said this is dead wrong the
soviets just jumped into a giant briar
patch you actually want to invite the
soviets to invade afghanistan just like
they should have been very happy about
the fact that we went into vietnam and
as i used to tell the chinese when i
first started going to china in the
early 2000s you should be very thankful
that the americans have invaded
afghanistan and iraq and you should tell
the americans that they should stay in
iraq and afghanistan until they win
because they'll be
forever wrecking their economy and
ruining their military at the same time
but how do you just to go back to world
war ii analogy
so you know we were it wasn't just
germany and japan we spent a lot of
resources there were those early covert
actions there was the marshall plan
especially in italy and in southern
europe to try to make keep it this the
communist hands off of it and we were
trying to promote something like a
democracy there i think it's fair to say
is the difference that the aim there was
ultimately to balance against the soviet
union and it had this realist
justification even if we're pursuing
these liberal using these liberal
tactics whereas in iraq it took on a
life of its own would that be the way to
think about it or some other yeah i
think just let's go back to world war ii
uh and the immediate aftermath right the
united states quickly figured out i'd
say by december 1947 that it had to
balance uh against uh the soviet union
that the europeans were no position to
do it certainly germany right so we
began to move in in a big way creating
nato in 1949
and everything we did was designed to
deal with that soviet threat now
part of the reason that we created
democracies at the time and the cia of
course was heavily involved in this was
because the alternative to democracy was
communism
because as most of you know
uh in the 1930s and during world war ii
it was the left that stood up to fascism
and the left therefore therefore had a
lot of cachet in places like france and
italy and we were very fearful that the
left would win and that the left if it
won in italy or one in france would form
an alliance with the soviet union so
promoting democracy had a very important
strategic rationale this is not to deny
your point that it also fit very neatly
with our liberal world view but it had a
different strategic rationale that's
different strategic rash now again what
you want to remember about the bush
doctrine is that the basic aim of the
bush doctrine was to create a giant zone
of peace by
making the middle east look like a bunch
of little americans
so so i have to say i'm convinced by
especially when we move off
even with iraq is a good example
afghanistan's a good example but
humanitarian intervention especially the
uh the
strikes in libya i think are a great
example for you they're driven by
liberalism with disastrous results
and it's accepting all of your examples
there's a puzzle isn't there why do we
keep doing this why don't why doesn't
you
what what what grip does this
attitude or this yeah have on
really as you call it the foreign policy
elite it crosses um political boundaries
where does it come from why does it have
this grip and why doesn't why don't we
learn i mean there's a lot of learning
to be had in reading your book but why
didn't the government figure that out on
its own yeah it's a it's a great
question uh
just to be very clear before i answer
jack's question i believe the
republicans and the democrats are
tweedledee and tweedlebum on foreign
policy i just hope that's clear
no
that's i meant to say that if i didn't
that's that's right there's no
meaningful difference between the two
parties with regard to foreign policy
they both embrace liberal hegemony
i think there are a number of reasons
first of all liberalism
is hardwired into
the american
psyche right americans are just deeply
committed to promoting liberalism around
the world because it's just the way we
are right that's one thing
they may not be there is that because
every nation tries to has a natural
tendency to replicate its domestic
structures abroad or is that something
america uniquely american
it's the former okay right the united
states is a fundamentally liberal
country at home and it does try to
export its foreign policy and it makes
perfect sense if you're an american
you're very proud of the fact that you
live in this great liberal democracy and
you believe that
america is exceptional and if you can
make everybody else look like us it'd be
a much better world i mean it's that
mentality that's driving us
for sure
but just to get to your question which
is a really great question i think there
are a number of factors at play here
jack i think first of all
once you get into these conflicts it's
almost impossible to get out
i mean look at afghanistan it's the
longest war in american history we got
out of iraq but then we got back in uh
this is one of the reasons i was so
opposed to going into iraq to begin with
i knew that once we got in there we'd
never get out so i think it perpetuates
itself for that reason
second i think it's a basic giant jobs
program for the elite here in washington
right
i mean they're just all sorts of people
in washington who i run around who i run
into all the time who want to run the
world if and if you trying to run the
world it just creates lots of jobs and
lots of opportunities so it is a jobs
program
uh and the other thing is we have no
accountability in the american system
you can screw up big time in foreign
policy and you really don't get punished
for it right you go to a think tank you
stay there for a couple years and then
you're back in the government again
why is that and so
so all of these things are puzzling
aren't they but why is there no
accountability in the foreign policy
establishment is that true across the
board in the government is there
something unique about the foreign
policy something unique about the
foreign policy establishment um
and that is the fact that there's this
real disjuncture between the public uh
and the elites
and the fact is the united states is the
most secure great power in the history
of the world
and the public intuits this
they understand that we're separated
from the rest of the world by two giant
moats we have thousands of nuclear
weapons and here we are in the unipolar
moment where by definition we're the
only great power on the planet just
think about this we're the only great
power on the planet we have thousands of
nuclear weapons and we're separated from
the rest of the world by giant moats
does it get any better than this
right so when people say the american
public really is not interested in
foreign policy they're correct the
american public is not that interested
in foreign policy because it doesn't
matter that much this is a playground
for the elites right and as i said
before it's a giant jobs program
and the end result is that as long as
large numbers of americans are not being
killed
and as long as people don't think they
now have to pay a lot of money to fight
these wars
they're willing to let the wars goes on
go on
and then my final point to you would be
the elite in this country is really
brilliant at bamboozling the public into
thinking it's necessary to spend all
this money on defense and fight all
these wars threat inflation is our
business there's nobody that's better at
threat inflation than the american
foreign policy establishment
so going back to a question i meant to
ask earlier is this you you define
liberal hegemony as i think you do as
only being possible in a unipolar era
correct right
um so
you focus on post 89 and really post
2001 in the book is there a precursor to
this i mean was the wilson era
was there another period of american
liberal gemini or is this a a recent is
this really post 89 1989 or post 2001
yeah my argument is that it's post 89
because we've never had unit polarity
before but to sort of pick up on your
point about wilson and other cases
there's no question that given what a
thoroughly liberal country the united
states is that that liberal impulse is
always there so even when you're in a
bipolar world or a multi-polar world the
inclination to follow liberal policies
is there and and occasionally you will
pursue a liberal policy and my argument
of course is that you'll get whacked on
the snout because
we live in a world where realism and
nationalism are the two dominant forces
and liberalism gets you in big trouble
especially in bipolarity and
multi-polarity it might be worth
explaining just for the general audience
what you mean when you say realism and
nationalism trump
liberal hedonity when they conflict that
those are the real motivators of
of action can you just flesh that out
for us yeah sure let me focus on
nationalism
that's a better one
i believe that nationalism is the most
powerful political ideology in the world
i believe it's no accident that we live
in a world that's populated with nation
states
i would add to you that i would add that
i think that the united states is a
thoroughly nationalist country
americans are very nationalistic
when
you hear americans talk about
american exceptionalism american
exceptionalism is american nationalism
at play
when madeleine albright who is a
card-carrying liberal
says that we are the indispensable
nation we stand taller we see further
just think about those words we
we as opposed to the other we stand
taller we see further that means we are
superior to other there's american
exceptionalism madeleine albright is
saying we americans
we as a nation state have the right we
have the responsibility and we have the
power to run around the world and
reorder the politics in different
countries in a liberal way but that's
very nationalistic thinking very
important to understand that okay
now
why do i believe that nationalism is
more powerful
than liberalism for one very simple
reason having to do with human nature
you have to decide when you think about
human beings whether you think they're
social animals
at their core who carve out space for
their individualism
or you think they're individuals who
form social contracts that's the sixty
four thousand dollar question you have
to ask yourself
liberalism
assumes
liberalism assumes that we are
individuals at our core who form social
contracts
nationalism assumes we are tribal from
the get-go we are born into nations
we're born into social groups we're born
into tribes and we carve out space for
our individualism
liberalism is wrong
and nationalism is right we are tribal
animals
right we belong to groups and we have
tremendous loyalty to those groups this
is not to say we can't carve out room
for our individualism right but we're
social animals so
when you get the united states of
america going into a country like iraq
or vietnam or the soviets going into
afghanistan
nationalism is automatically going to
come to the fore in that country you
have invaded because those people are
going to say we are a sovereign nation
state we believe in self-determination
we do not want the united states coming
in and telling us what to do and think
about
how we react to the soviet this would be
the russians
interfering in our elections
they do not have any right we believe to
interfere
in an american election it's a violation
of our sovereignty that's nationalism at
play nationalism dominates liberalism
okay
um
and okay good um
what are i just want just to just to be
to follow through what is an ex but how
does this play out how does that idea
play out in sort of american part
foreign policy failures when we the
point is when we try to invade on these
principles it often doesn't work because
we simply can't go in there and impose
this form of government because
the impulse to nationalism resist that
is that the point yeah but look
american foreign policy as i said to you
before
american foreign policy in the era of
liberal hegemony has a principal goal
has three goals but the principal goal
is to promote liberal democracy around
the world it's to knock off
authoritarian regimes and turn them into
liberal democracies okay
that means that the united states of
america is going to interfere
with
the sovereignty of other countries
and this is going to cause problems not
only in the middle east with the iraq's
and the iran's and the saudi arabias
it's going to cause problems with the
russians and with the chinese if you go
to russia or you go to china today and
you talk to them about whether they
think it's a good idea that america is
promoting democracy
in either
russia or china they will tell you and
know on certain terms that this is
categorically unacceptable
they recoil at the idea of us
interfering in their politics as much as
we recall at the idea of them
interfering in our politics this is
nationalism right so this this point
about
the russians recoiling to us interfering
in their politics as much as we recall
uh
to them interfering in ours i think is a
fundamental point this is
for me when i read realism literature
versus
liberalism literature
realism for me has two foundational
elements one is it tends to assess
situations in an amoral way not to make
normative judgments about various forms
of life just in trying to understand
international relations
and to what you just said
and you make this point over and over
again about the moving moving nato east
and the impact that had and if we just
imagined as many people argued that it
was going to have this devastating
impact on russia and cause it to react
in a very harsh way
realist
tell me this is accurate realists tend
to think in those
uh
in terms of seeing through the eyes of
the enemy and taking that very seriously
in a kind of
cold and amoral way and my sense is is
that liberal internationalists
are don't do that as much they they and
i don't know this is fair or not i
wonder what you think that they tend not
to think how is this going to be seen
from the other side and tend just to do
what they think is right is that a fair
characterization which part of that
would you disagree with i agree with
everything and i'll give you the logic
that i see that sits behind it
realists basically
treat states as black boxes
there are no good guys or bad guys in
the real story and realists assume that
states even your own state often has to
do terrible things
because the principal goal is survival
and survival requires you to sometimes
do immoral things uh for purposes of
maximizing your chances of survival
there are no good guys and bad guys in
the real story therefore it's quite easy
for a realist to put him or herself in
the shoes of the other side right
liberals on the other hand divide the
world into good guys and bad guys i'm
sure that most of you in this room share
that view you believe that liberal
democracies are the good guys and
authoritarian states are the bad guys
and when you have that world view
and you're in a liberal state and you're
dealing with an authoritarian state it's
virtually impossible for you to put
yourself in the shoes of that
authoritarian state and in fact you
think that you're a benign hegemon right
i've talked to mike mcfaul who was the
american ambassador to moscow from 2012
to 2014
and he was shocked by
what happened in february 2014 when the
ukraine crisis blew up
because he told putin and putin's
lieutenants on numerous occasions when
he was the ambassador that they really
had nothing to fear
from nato expansion because the united
states was a benign hegemon it had
benign motives and i believe that mike
believed that completely
but from the russian point of view
the united states did not look like a
benign hegemon especially since the
united states was talking ultimately
about regime change in russia
but it was i believe almost impossible
for mike to understand that because he's
such a thorough going liberal whereas
for a realist like me it makes perfect
sense this is why george kennan and
virtually all the realists said from the
get-go that nato expansion is going to
lead to disaster because they could put
themselves in the shoes of the russians
so you talk at the end of the book about
the case for restraint as you call it
which is i think it's fair to say the
realest prescription for american
foreign policy which is a restrained
foreign policy could you outline that
well
just imagine what the world would have
looked like
from let's say 1990
up to the present if i had been the
president of the united states and had
been in charge of american foreign
policy don't worry that was never going
to happen
uh
we would have had no nato expansion
and we would today have much better
relations with the russians
the situation in the middle east would
be much more stable
we would not have invaded iraq we would
not have
helped kill colonel gaddafi in libya we
would not have gotten deeply involved in
syria
all these escapades and i think the end
result is that many fewer people would
have died many few americans would have
died we would have spent much less money
i also would have pulled all our troops
out of europe when the cold war ended
i find it unacceptable that we spend all
this money defending europeans who are
perfectly capable of defending
themselves when we have such great needs
in this country
you go to airports like laguardia and
lax they're basically third world
airports
and you go all around the world and
people at first
world airports i mean the amount of
money we've poured into these wards is
remarkable so we would have had a much
more restrained foreign policy based on
the fact
that we respected
the power of nationalism and we're
mainly concerned with the balance of
power and how do you i tend to agree
with those judgments but they depend on
counter counter factual assessments
and i think it's easier to make the
counterfactual assessment in the middle
east because we seem to have created
such a mess but
it just seems to be harder to know i
agree with you that expanding nato
eastward seemed to invite trouble and to
seem to threaten the russians in a way
that may have been unnecessary
but the combination of not of of not
just not expanding nato but disbanding
it how do you know in your
counterfactual world that wouldn't have
led to russian aggression i mean how do
you think about that kind of russia was
a complete basket case in the 1990s
even today there's virtually no chance
that russia is going to conquer eastern
europe they've been there done that it
did not work out very well they got out
of town and the last thing they want to
do is go back in furthermore russia is a
declining great power largely for
demographic reasons but also for
economic reasons
but let's assume that i'm wrong let's
assume that you know
they have some formidable military power
why can't the europeans defend
themselves they have many more people
than the russians have combined they
have much more wealth
and they spend a lot more on defense
despite the fact that they don't spend
that much on defense why are we
defending them
i agree with barack obama when he said
we should have concentrated on nation
building at home not spending all these
money well there's money on wars that
number one never end and number two that
we lose okay so
that's a lot of what you said today
sounds like some of the things that
president trump advocated for on the
campaign trail you don't talk much about
president trump
um you know he was first of all very
much against elitist control of u.s
foreign policy
he is very skeptical of nato he's
skeptical in attitude about
excessive us international engagement
even though he engaged in humanitarian
intervention twice in syria
so i just wonder what you what the
relationship is between your thesis and
the trump foreign policy if you can
state what that is it's kind of hard to
tell and more generally how do you
assess
the trump foreign policy from the
perspective of is it committed to
liberal hegemony or something else going
on
yeah a lot of questions i know to answer
them all please
answer any of the ones you want and i'll
follow up yeah if i answer when you
don't answer two you can come back at me
on two
first thing to say about president trump
is that when he was candidate trump
he ran against liberal hegemony remember
i said there were three elements to
liberal hegemony spreading democracy all
over the world he made it clear we were
getting out of the business of doing
that
number two uh
purveying a open international economic
order he made it very clear that he
likes tariffs and he was interested in
encountering this open international
economic order which he thought it'd
hurt us and with regard to institutions
uh he does not like nato he does not
like the eu he does not like uh the wto
nafta
i don't know i think one of the first
things he did when he became president
was to throw the tpp in the garbage uh
so he doesn't like institutions
i often say i think as candidates go he
was the most radical foreign policy
candidate
in american history i mean he ran
against the establishment and by the way
have you ever asked yourself why did he
win he won because large chunks of the
american people understand that our
foreign policy is bankrupt right
and by the way barack obama ran against
liberal hegemony as well although
liberal hegemony defeated him once he
was in office although by the end of by
the end of his term he basically had
admitted
i think in the last two or three years
especially after libya he felt burned by
it yeah he felt burned by it there's no
question then the famous uh interview
with jeffrey goldberg in the atlantic i
think captures that very any any
resisted those impulses right for the
last two years
so what you have here now
given that almost everyone in washington
is committed to liberal hegemony is you
have trump and maybe a handful of others
who are up against the establishment and
the question is who's going to win
remember this was the situation that
obtained with obama and obama lost
i think there's nobody with as much
agency as donald trump and
i think if there's anybody who can beat
back liberal hegemony it's him
but the argument i would make jack is i
think liberal hegemony is done for it
anyway
and it's not done for it because of
donald trump
it's done for it because of the rise of
china because
you want to remember my argument is you
can only have liberal hegemony in a
unipolar world and we are or i would
argue we already have moved out of a
unipolar world with the rise of china
and the resurrection of russian power we
now live in a multi-polar world so we're
going back to real realpolitik
and what does what does that mean for um
so we're going back to real politique
because we live in this multipolar world
what does that mean concretely for the
role that
human rights rhetoric plays in our
foreign policy obama kind of dropped it
actually to a surprising degree trump
certainly isn't mentioning it do you
think that means the human rights
element of our foreign policy that goes
back i guess to carter do you think that
kind of goes by the wayside it certainly
is not a driver of policy is that right
yeah my my argument is that
liberalism which would include an
emphasis on human rights i i just meant
that as an element of liberalism yes
right
will always
be there to describe our foreign policy
no matter how real politique it is i
often say that during the cold war the
united states acted in a real politique
way and disguised it with liberal
rhetoric right so the rhetoric will
always be there the argument i'm making
is that we actually behaved in a liberal
fashion during the post-cold war world
but those days are gone now
one could argue that there are two real
problems that liberal hegemony faces
number one is the rise of china and the
resurrection of russian power that's one
and number two is it's so clear now that
the policy has failed and given the fact
that donald trump is in the white house
and he's been pounding at liberal
hegemony that sort of one-two punch has
in a very important way finished it off
okay
thank you very much that was a great
discussion thank you
we're here to announce the death knell
of liberal hegemony
thank you john so john's happy to to we
don't take questions but john's happy to
sign books and chat and like i assume
sure
forever
thank you all for coming
c-span launched book tv